en fait la mairie estime que 10 millions
de personnes ont fait le déplacement
pour venir voir ron 0 autant dire
qu'elle est en train de devenir une
attraction ce qui met les autorités un
peu mal à l'aise
pascal golomer tristan le brasse ils
viennent pour voir par tous les moyens
voir derrière les grilles derrière les
ouvriers qui s'affairent jours et demi
cet immense chantier qui est devenue
grande 0 comme une lente procession la
foule piétine autour du site le plus
visité de new york aujourd'hui 10
millions de personnes depuis le mois de
septembre lieu de curiosité lieu de
pèlerinage pour moi c'est comme visiter
un cimetière
je voulais que les gamins voisins c'est
une partie de notre histoire
une partie de l'histoire des états unis
on a un devoir à faire pour l'école sur
le world trade center il y à de
l'émotion de la tristesse la volonté de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé ce jour là
est un peu d'espoir aussi parfois le
fait que tous ces gens soient simplement
réunit aujourd'hui de voir tout le monde
rassemblé oui cela a quelque chose de
réconfortant de l'autre côté de la rue
ce sont les marchands du temps ils
n'étaient que quelques-uns il ya six
mois
ils sont aujourd'hui dès 10 heures
souvenirs t-shirt gadgets rien d'illégal
dans tout cela rien d'indécent non plus
vous diront les vendeurs il ya bien une
épicerie qui fait des affaires à côté je
vois pas la différence
et puis il ya ceux qui travaillaient
déjà dans le quartier avant le 11
septembre
ils sont revenus quelques jours quelques
semaines plus tard et vivent désormais
une étrange cohabitation
quand on sait que tant de gens sont
morts ici voir ce lieu de venir en
attraction touristique qu'avec tous ces
vendeurs c'est un peu pénible pour nous
la cohabitation va pourtant se prolonger
pendant plusieurs années le temps que le
quartier se reconstruise et tentent de
vivre à nouveau normalement